you
here we go team black okay I got a focus
here hmm I'm thinking about c5 and
knight c6 I'm also thinking about Fein
Kettering what's unprotected this guy
and this guy but none of them are
accessible for when one of these pawns
move so I'm thinking about this here
here here I'd really like to get in c5
Knight c6 breathing space for my rope
what would I do if pawn push here okay
they're not going with that so I like
this already and maybe I should play
here yeah I'm gonna do this right now
no if I do this pawn push and then if I
take bishop here or if I would have
moved it maybe next I'll do this so d v
g6 Bishop g7 I imagine this is best
they're not doing that this could be
problematic now I think for white how do
you deal with this pawn advance this duo
okay you're going with that hmm but the
bishop be slightly exposed like could I
know you know what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna take and my night out
okay for a second I was thinking could
the Queen come out here I have that
defendant I am actually thinking about
night here and Bishop here odd as that
may seem I'd really like to get rid of
this fish up I might need to mute the
stream I think I might be ready to
sneeze okay I think it went away false
alarm
okay so they're prepping this but I
don't think they have enough support for
it could do this let's get this in first
though I'm abandoning the idea of being
Kettering this is pretty much a tell
because I would never play e6 and g6 and
weaken this f6 square like that no way
not happening not allowing it
d5 takes takes or I could take because
my knight is here to defend my rook if
there is a capture so I was gonna do
this next with Bishop c5 but now they're
stopping it here's met with this I think
my knight needs to reposition but well
yeah let me do that I want my knight on
f6 so my Knights are gonna end up
classically developed classical squares
f6 and c6 even on time let's get here
and get my bishop probably to d6
pointing at something there's no pin F
to worry about so I'm not gonna go here
here's better
of course I make this maybe easier to
get in and this seemed too weird I want
to get my Bishop work and let's
I don't want to go opposite the rook are
they gonna take the palm let's see
you should I was gonna go to this square
but maybe over here is better Knight f5
might not be so bad Bishop takes I do
this and I get this pawn I get rid of
their light squared Bishop there's some
weaknesses that I could potentially
exploit imagine a queen here one day
night here something like that maybe
this maybe I don't even need to Castle I
like this idea just clearing the way for
Bishop c6 around with that three minute
warning
yeah this is a not sure about that I
also consider putting pressure on this
so if takes I'm gonna go with the night
where do I like this post I might
actually like the night better on f6 or
f5 mmm okay so they're not so quick to
do
hmm that's so quick to trade bishops hmm
this pond is hit twice I was just ready
to do this we'll be dropping that huh
interesting
I really don't want to deal with the
pawn on e4 an e4 f4 structure so I was
considering this allowing the damaging
the structure Castle King here rook G I
can still Castle queenside and so can i
I shouldn't know to do
all right I guess I'm gonna try to cope
with this structure c5 next and then
retreat my bishop or what about b5
okay this because my bishop I can't rely
upon anymore to defend this square it
could be kicked need to get castled now
that there's a completely open file the
rooks are kneading and going to have to
contribute we're really dead even on
time I don't want to take as I help them
develop so let me come all the way back
now not all the way back here's
sufficient my knight is there to defend
so if Queen takes I'm definitely taking
with the broke I'm one move away from
being fully developed if we have a queen
trade now maybe I don't want to well
yeah let's let's castle can't really do
without castle in here so I'm keeping
the tension and I want to keep the
knight out of here and have a new square
for my bishop now that there's no Bishop
takes e5 I have a moment here to get
that in with this let's get here why
doesn't careful maybe I'll avoid the
Queen exchange and then try and exploit
the King position so I think maybe he's
now now is the time to trade Queens
although she seems tucked in quite well
on this Square even after a bishop
exchange whoa now I'm gonna have this
light square diagonal that moon was
coming though I'm gonna take Queen takes
I get to enter on the seventh though
dead even on time I'm on the pond the
bishop it needs to let's do this I don't
want to trade rook so easily have these
knight hops the Knights in a pin
let's keep control over this file on
push I do this
I'd have five okay get my knight
involved it would be a bunch of rook
trades here let's go let's go let's go
around this pond if rook can't come back
over here I have pressured I want to
keep pressure on c3 King position a good
night position my bishop not the
greatest piece in the world less than a
minute do I take now let's grab some
space he's very ugly tall pons syndrome
oh but now they could do this ah I
really want to keep my rook though I
want to keep my rook active my knight
could cause some headaches too throat
goes too far I could get this guy he's a
bad Bishop but he's controlling an
important pond I could also pin the
bishop if he goes after my pawn actually
I don't even know how the rook tries to
attack him let's do this I want to break
it be 385 of takes I do this whoa
totally missed that back here stay
active with the rook is the plan to keep
pressure here let's come back over King
position my king in a better position
man it's take and
I don't even know what I want to do try
this my king needs to come over on f5 I
think my bishop is gonna get kicked
around off my king goes too far
time burner just king over is fine
another time burner I want to get this
move in I should okay let's come over
here and then get my bishop here okay
and now I still don't want to trade I'm
gonna try something a little reckless a
four takes and then b3 and then get this
c4 pawn track him down or him actually
let me get him first since he's passed
the bishop could have been there to
defend though Wow
good game man hmm good game I was just
fishing for stuff right there at the end
they're saying that they're in it they
had internet lag issues I hate those
legs right that happens though alright
let's let's go back here Fisher and them
what an interesting start here from your
perspective yeah I'm always really
really drawn to these moves identify the
rook at fees but if there's a rook on
one of these four files C D E or F I
really like pushing upon two squares
especially if you can follow up with
having the knight right behind it which
was my idea here it just this
configuration nothing sophisticated but
just having the night right
the pond there's the support squares on
b4 and d4 which are nice nice nice
possibilities yeah there's a bunch of
people like pointing out Queen d4 stuff
oh my goodness right here oh man you
serious
ah ah thanks for putting that out I feel
wonderful right now everybody's going
bonkers in the twitch chat right now
Queen d4 you fool fork town oh man yeah
that would have been nice right I would
have been game over
so blundered by white and a counter
blunder by black
yeah missed opportunity nice Queen d4
check good by bishop could got a goodbye
game man alright there's an improvement
okay move noted I like this Knight move
that was nice i I was kind of torn here
I mean he's he's hitting a lot of points
here C 5 f6 quite limited could I have
done something better
where could white have done something
better okay clearly white has to do
something other than this well if this
isn't played then
my Center might be well I don't know
maybe D 3 and E 4 is an idea just
building a center where's the first
advance pawn f4 you could get this guy
up right next to him it's usually a good
thing pawns work well in duo's - two
pawns here on e4 and f4 which is
eventually what happened when I took on
e4 and then that eventually granted a
space advantage to white now I think the
better approach right here is to not go
elsewhere with that Queen yeah well I
mean it's quickly realized the Queen
comes right back over to e2 but nothing
really was gained right there
in fact I I mean you're the better side
look at this pawn structure it's
excellent look at your king position the
only thing I have working for me is a
rook in your position but you neutralize
that look c2 I avoid the trades but
eventually you are able to just get them
in and I like your Bishop is just
awesome it's just as a very solid game
missed I missed move early on by both of
us but I'm just fishing for stuff here
at the end I think when it comes to this
sequence of pawn advances nothing's
happening right there but as soon as
upon advance happens it's time to
reassess so after a 5 or a 4 takes b3
but I am gonna get one of these guys
back there even in the final position
when there was a lot some time Bishop
here although I have row K for here I'm
not sure we're both just moving fast at
this point
or maybe he resigned I don't know either
way it was both low on time very tight
game the whole way through aside from
that early blunder by both of us
okay good game